these are what we call axes axes plural
for axis okay so now what there's a
vertical axis they do much I shall my I
might leave these along with half me off
yeah you can come in fiction okay the
twenties okay so like we said there is a
vertical axis this one here right and we
tend to maybe info y-axis
I'll talk about why in a second actually
right then the other one is called the
x-axis
now it's vitally important you always
label them because in the future they
would always be X&Y there'll be things
like time and distance or temperature or
any quantities you like but importantly
we're thinking about them as our
positions in space positions in space so
you have these axes here where they meet
is called the origin right what is your
then okay the origin
we've run out sorry about take this take
this
okay now yeah so it's it's two things
there's two things it's nicely ambiguous
it's all for origin but also it's it's a
zero because this is like our starting
point okay hey you guys you guys I I
would love to go through this video so
that you understand but we all need to
cooperate on it you may well decide no
Mass General I know where I'm headed I
don't really need to pay attention to
this and that's fine that's your call
but other people may have made a
different decision to you and so we'll
have to spend this time in class
differently to how you go so I ask that
you respect that good now these axes
right vertical horizontal they are
exactly exactly the same as do you
remember when you keep picking this one
up when you learnt about the number line
the number line right you just have one
line and you like stuck a zero in the
middle okay and then you could indicate
Oh where's 1 or 5 or negative 2 right
and so you put on you know your label a
few points that kind of piece that one
simply four would be over here you know
you could put on something like negative
one and a half you get the picture
that's number line so all that this is
is there's another line this way and
there's a number line this way that's
all no big deal
now on this number line here this is one
dimensional okay so if I want to
describe to you where am I all I need is
a number like 4 or negative 1 in a half
if I provide that number to you you
unambiguously know where I am
look here I am at 4
okay but if I sent you just one number
right if I said 4
I could be all over the place where am I
I want to be able to describe where this
person is one dimension you Steve what
number two dimensions you need two
numbers right so for example let's put
this on here okay so do some markings
for me okay let's go 1 2 3 4 right so
above that this is the x-value the first
one it goes alphabetically that's a 4
right and I go up let's see 1 2 go
so there's two and there's cool can you
see just like before what number for one
dimension I know where I am
two numbers for two dimensions I know
where I am as well hmm
yes we will we will very roughly now
these two numbers that I keep talking
about right they are the coordinates of
coordinate geometry ok so this pair of
numbers is just the way to say well
where am I like in relation to that
where I started am i up here or down
there or that's all that means
it's a bullet meet now the guy who
really started like his sisters would
use for agents but the guy who really
started using you might have seen you
textbook is a French guy named Rene
Descartes
and from the second half of his last
name that's where we get the other name
for the state which is the Cartesian the
Cartesian plane
so if you've never heard before now you
have okay this this set of axes right
this up this 2d space it's a plane right
like flat things like you know like when
you you've got a new boy when you've got
a plane okay
it's a flat thing stand out to this guy
because he was the one who really used
that now showing others how can this be
a beneficiary